hi reject nation I'm Greg Elbe I'm John
we're gonna watch from one of the most
famous movie studios and profitable one
right below Disney 8:24 is under the
Silver Lake official trailer it is from
the director of it follows a movie I
have yet to have seen hate me all you
want for not having watched it yet
that's okay I also haven't seen Forrest
Gump or Shawshank Redemption you call
yourself a movie guy apparently cuz
there's more movies than those three
John yeah I a part of the intro is done
here watch this trailer totally and paid
for the day shout out today I was gonna
go out to none other than Tony McGuire
team chief headphones on because we've
had sinking problems let's do this that
crackle he's playing another religious
character
besides buying up earlier it feels like
a 70s movie
[Music]
like it feels like one she dead
wow that's quick nothing strange about
she wanted to leave how does that not
make sense I don't understand why and
she didn't tell me ladies she didn't
like you maybe she knows you're poor and
haven't paid your rent from Silver Lake
to the Hollywood Hills could any of this
be connected to Sarah I knew this girl
there's a message in the music it is
maybe there are people more important
than us communicating things in the
world only them enough yeah oh you think
that's weird
[Music]
hoping to win a prize
oh cool what is this 60 70s it's taking
place in because it did feel like a 70s
movie to me more than just its era like
the way it was kind of being captured
reminding me of that then it feels a
little more modern as a trivet kept
progressing yeah it definitely seems
like it's borrowing both from new are
and from you know that 70s vibe I almost
got not not in a similar plot way but
I've thought about inherent vice during
this I got a psychological it's gonna
starve just quirky and weird and then
it's gonna progressively get darker and
this guy's gonna deteriorate over the
course of the movie and as it keeps
going I feel like you might get a little
bit more of that scarier touch this
guy's last movie being it follows
everyone and yeah I like that he's doing
a completely different type of genre
switch up here but there's still some
awesome visual flair to it so happy
Andrew Garfield's not doing some like
heavy ass performance great job it's
nice to see him having a little bit of
fun yeah yeah and it looks like this is
probably gonna flirt with the surreal it
looks like kind of like a twisting
turning kind of movie with a lot of
details and plot turn it feels like Paul
Thomas Anderson meets Wes Anderson I
mean that excites me and I yeah like you
said it's not a flat-out horror by any
stretch but I would not be at all
surprised if this at least flirts with
the sinister I think by second half of
act 2 it's gonna start getting it just
looks like that this this seems like one
of those awesome psychological
deterioration stories I think this dude
just has a substan some mysterious code
that I don't think you'll crack in the
end I've doubt you will I don't know I
mean I'm sure he'll get at least far
enough to have a compelling journey and
I you know I like the David Robert
Mitchell like you said is going to a
different style and especially with the
music I mean I don't know if this is
gonna be the music we get in the movie
but it follows was one of the big
harbingers of the 80s
synth throwback score and so I'm happy
that he's not you know just returning to
the same stuff again for this it seems
like he's really branching out with this
one knowing what I've heard from it
follows and just seeing the trailer I
like movies where the music is like song
as we know songs from the era is gonna
probably be the soundtrack for this
movie feels like it'll probably be
edited certain sequences will be edited
to that kind of song like I imagined
scenes that written were probably with
these songs in mind and stuff like that
yeah it seems like music in general is
gonna play a big part in this because
there are so many records spinning and
there's at least that one room with all
those instruments in it they had coming
back to and stuff like that all right
well that was fun that was fun cool I
mean it's one of the rare not looking a
24 depressing films so I'm happy about
that
no I'm just intense and hip no I'm kind
of stark and oh yeah it's like an
appearing a 24 just kind of hover around
that all the time this could be weirdly
funny Tony McGuire page from the day
shout out for you buddy wanted to give
you a shout out here because you are
heavily into music music man you're one
of the paint we have like a couple of
patrons who are super super about their
music and if there's one guy I know who
really knows his history of music it is
you my friend and I could totally see
you evolving into this kind of guy right
here definitely a dude who loves his
jams then meets some chick and then gets
obsessed over her and just doesn't
decide to move on and find someone new
like yeah you crushed on a chick why are
you getting obsessed Tony
you reek of these qualities you reek of
a shy kind of guy who has
obsessive-compulsive disorder inside of
him and just gets passionate and
fantasized about some chick but just
know it's okay to try to track them down
no matter what I will not discourage you
from doing that yeah yeah be responsible
out there but not saying like hurt her
scene find love oh yeah yeah track it
down at all costs
and bring a bow and arrow along with you
cuz you never know when you're gonna get
into trouble that's yeah ones are Crips
in LA and I mean just who's gonna expect
you with a bow and arrow unless you know
so much quieter
hey subscribe to the real rejects let's
to go in your patron that notification
Valley get notified every time a vid of
ours is up and check us out on patreon
weekly Q&A is full-length TV show
reactions over there I would love to
have you